today on the matt wall show a major
health magazine puts out an issue
celebrating fatness and calling for gyms
and fitness instructors to be better fat
allies and it's not a satire it's all
very real also joe biden cusses out a
fox reporter how would the media have
reacted if trump did the same thing to
someone at say cnn and amid talk of war
for the sake of protecting ukraine the
white house is asked why america should
put itself at risk to protect europe if
europe won't protect itself it's a good
question the answer was not so great
though also the ladies of the view agree
that they may never feel comfortable in
public again without a mask because of
everything we've learned during the
pandemic but what have we learned
exactly and finally in our daily
cancellation lena dunham is back on the
scene and it didn't take long for her to
get canceled we'll talk about all that
and more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as we all know inflation is out of
control and it's not projected to get
better any time soon that's why it's
never been more important to rethink how
we shop and how we choose the brands
that are effective safe and in it for
the long haul our partner naturally it's
clean can help naturally it's clean is
dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the cost reducing
your waste and reducing other harmful
chemicals in your home as well their
safer chemistry solutions utilize
nature's powerful plant-based enzymes to
clean every area of your home from the
bathroom to your hardwood floors to your
kitchen all of it can be clean with
naturally it's clean now you might be
wondering what does this have to do with
inflation natural it's clean is here to
help you save big on the cleaning
solutions you use every day by offering
many of their top cleaning solutions as
a concentrate formula
many of their concentrate solutions will
yield 12 bottles driving down the cost
per bottle and allow you to save big
giving your budget the break it deserves
and somebody with four kids i can tell
you that um and you know this if you're
a parent that cleaning products becomes
a big part of your life it becomes a big
part of your budget as well naturally
it's clean can make that a lot um more
painless for you so try it for yourself
right now my listeners can get their
hands on the naturally it's clean daily
wire essential kit stocked with four
great products for fifteen percent off
simply visit naturallyitsclean.com matt
news promo code matt to save an
additional 15 off your order don't delay
a break from
a break from buy inflation is here try
out these incredible cleaning products
in your home today by visiting
naturallyitsclean.com
for more information
so the first month of the new year
usually means big business for the
fitness industry people across the
country are looking back at our previous
year reflecting on the collective hours
and days spent lying around like slugs
consuming three times as many calories
as we burn off on a good day our
waistlines expanding to blimp-like
proportions feeling the fleeting pains
of guilt for all of this remembering
that both sloth and gluttony are deadly
sins and uh thus
resolving to finally begin engaging in
some form of physical movement in the
year ahead of course the problem is that
once we embark on our new health and
wellness quest we discover that exercise
is you know difficult
and uh worst of all it takes up time
that could be better spent watching tick
tock videos and so the resolve dies away
and the gyms empty out as quickly as
they were filled though most of the
people who abandoned their gym routine
still continue paying their membership
fees hoping that at least
being a dues paying member of a gym
might you know count for something as if
heart disease will see their membership
card on their keychain and pass them
over on that basis alone
the fitness industry does not need you
to actually get healthy and fit it just
needs you to see health and fitness as
at least theoretically desirable
but what happens when these things
health and fitness and general physical
wellness
can no longer be presented as even
theoretically desirable
that's when you end up with absurdities
like the latest issue of self magazine
now self is an online publication
allegedly focused on health and beauty
and owned by the same mega corporation
that gives us vogue the new yorker gq
vanity fair wired
pretty much every other magazine in
existence it would seem
self's first issue of 2022 looks so on
the nose
so perfectly representative of all of
the foibles of wokeness that you might
at first think it's some kind of
intentional self-parody
and it is self-parity but it's just not
intentional as you can see on the cover
here um it features an obese woman in
spandex
along with the headline
the future of fitness
and one wonders if the next issue will
have a picture of a square with the
headline the future of circles or the
number five with the headline the future
of two plus two
in any case the subheadings on the cover
promise to give us more information
about quote the relentless reality of
anti-fatness in fitness and quote four
ways to respond to unnecessary
encouragement at the gym
yeah you know all those bullies at the
gym that uh encourage you
an introductory article by the
editor-in-chief lita shy
explains the point and purpose of this
health magazine's new focus on promoting
obesity she writes quote
in this digital issues articles and
essays when we say future we're not
talking about the latest fitness
trackers or streaming workout equipment
we're talking about the people who are
changing the landscape of an industry
that has for too long excluded many over
the past few years thanks to the body
positivity movement as well as other
thoughtful explorations that have
challenged complacent ideas about weight
and size
we've seen an important shift in how we
discuss larger bodies
but fitness spaces can be a final
frontier in a particular strain of body
discrimination where anti-fat bias and
weight related stigma are entrenched in
our collective understanding of what it
means to be fit
it's time to break free from this
limited view the future of fitness is
about making space for everyone to feel
welcome
so in this package we're celebrating the
people who are helping get us there
now clicking through to discover the
whole package we find articles with
titles like quote
12 pieces of running gear that can make
running in larger bodies more
comfortable
now i know what can make running in
larger bodies more comfortable
a salad but i'm guessing that doesn't
make it on the list other titles here's
how to find a gym that's size friendly
and quote these 10 people are
challenging how the fitness industry
treats fatness and then how to feel
competent at the gym when you're
starting out according to 12 larger
bodied exercisers
now please note the updated pc lingo
here
a fat guy at the gym is no longer a fat
guy at the gym he is now a larger bodied
exerciser
if all of this doesn't sound inane
enough
then how about this headline
six things fitness instructors should do
to become a better fat ally
and quote seven seemingly empowering
body positive phrases that actually
reinforce ableism
and then my favorite
seven ways to repair your relationship
with movement
now i love that last one because it
provides a very useful framework for
laziness which of course is what is what
all of this is really doing
but um now when my wife asks me for a
third time to get off the couch and go
take the garbage cans out i can just say
sorry honey
i'm really working on my relationship
with movement right now
we've decided to take some time apart
and it's for the best
can you bring me another beer by the way
i need you to be a fat ally honey
now it's easy enough to laugh at all
this because it's so interminably stupid
but
unfortunately this stuff doesn't just
live on tumblr tumblr blogs and weird
internet forums anymore this is a health
magazine
published by one of the largest media
companies on the planet
imagine if men's health
put out an issue on alcoholism but every
article just encouraged you to keep
drinking as much booze as you want
six things you can do to be a better
binge drinker ally
here's how to find an aaa meeting that's
byob
these 10 drunk drivers are challenging
how the court system treats impaired
driving
for now anyway though this could change
as we continue our slide down the
slippery slope everyone would agree that
such content would be not only
ridiculous but harmful evil even
as it would actively encourage people to
destroy themselves it's like finding a
suicidal man standing at the edge of the
roof
and shouting you should totally jump if
you want to don't let anyone judge you
if you jump maybe you can fly only one
way to find out
and this is why of course fat acceptance
will never be anything but morally
perverse and repulsive
it's like bulimia acceptance or the
acceptance of people who cut their
wrists
to love someone is to will their good
that is to help them towards
um
towards
what is good for them but if you're
helping them towards degradation despair
and destruction
that's hatred
or at least indifference
this is also why obesity is not an
identity
it's the erasure of identity
both because it will kill you
i mean literally erasing you physically
from existence
and also because it covers
the defining parts of you
it will always be absurd to claim that a
morbidly obese woman is physically
beautiful
she's not
because her feminine features are
covered in lard i mean you may as well
say someone is most beautiful when they
have a blanket over their heads
beautiful in this context context is a
description of physical features but
morbid obesity overtakes all of your
physical features covers and destroys
them
so that when you call a morbidly obese
person physically beautiful
you must be describing the obesity
itself as beautiful
which is to say that destruction and
sickness are beautiful
which is itself a sick thing to say
this is the backwards world we find
ourselves in when self-perception reigns
perceive
supreme it's a problem we talk about
often on this show because it lies at
the root of almost everything
that's going wrong in our culture
in a world where the ego is king
the job of everyone around you is to
reinforce how you perceive yourself or
how you at least want to perceive
yourself
because you shouldn't have to conform
yourself to any outside reality there's
no truth greater than your truth your
will your ego
so if you want to feel healthy and
beautiful as everybody does
then society must simply declare
that you are both of those things
it would be an act of unthinkable
oppression
for anyone to tell you that though you
want to be those things you're not
even if they lay out a plan and they
promise to help you become what you want
to be
if they say you're not those things
right now
but you can be
here's how to do it i'll help you even
that is oppressive
because it implies that there's a truth
and reality greater than the individual
ego something that the individual must
navigate through
rules that he has to follow
and the modern narcissist simply cannot
accept that
so he stares in the mirror
tells himself fairy tales about himself
and everybody plays along
cheering him on
and on and on and on
and all the way over the ledge
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i don't know about you but one
of my biggest resolutions for the year
2022 is to stop wasting so much time in
the auto parts store right i mean this
is just hours and cumulatively days that
are wasted with the ever-increasing
numbers of cars and makes and models it
is now impossible to stock all the parts
you need in a traditional chain
storefront why endure often pointless or
seemingly intimidating questions
if you're a real man you should never be
intimidated by questions at the auto
parts store but i am cause i'm not a
real man
why endure that when uh you know many
times the guy behind the counter he's
not gonna have the parts he needs anyway
he's gonna have to order it on his
computer well you have the computer
yourself you can access rockauto.com at
home and in your pocket rockauto.com is
a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are always low and they're
the same no matter who you are reliably
low prices amazing selection all the
parts you'll ever need rockauto.com go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and write walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you
all right another cheerful opening model
like you always get those from this show
um
you know the other the other point i
wanted to make about that um is uh this
of course we find that this
inclusivity idea
the gyms have to be inclusive of uh of
everyone and of course in in a certain
way they they already are i mean it's if
you're out of shape then the gym's for
you
um come come in and uh and get into
better shape
it's um you know it's like from a moral
and spiritual perspective
uh churches
are supposed to be inclusive of sinners
which is a good thing because we all are
if they weren't then none of us could go
but inclusive in the sense that come and
be healed
become a better person
you know that inclusive in that way
but if we mean inclusive in that it has
to just
belong to everyone equally
with no real goal or purpose in mind
well when that becomes the focus of any
institution or anything
it just means that you're erasing that
institution
in inclusivity itself
for its own sake cannot be the primary
point of anything
because in order for anything to be
anything it must not be everything that
it isn't okay does that now i'm
confusing myself
um sometimes when you're dealing with
concepts that are so insane you have to
you have to state these simple realities
that it almost sounds crazy because you
have to say it out loud
so in order for football to be football
it has to not be baseball or basketball
if a steakhouse wants to be a steakhouse
it has to specialize in making steaks
not in making seven thousand different
things
if the boy scouts want to be the boy
scouts it has to have only boys that's
why it's the boy scouts of course that's
not the case anymore that's why the boy
scouts effectively doesn't exist
once inclusivity becomes the point
include everyone
and see them all is totally equal
there's no specific purpose or point
here
that you have to conform yourself to
well then it's just there's there's no
point
might as well not exist
all right let's start with uh this biden
president biden
appeared at a you know did a rare
appearance in front of um the media
yesterday
and uh as things were wrapping up he was
asked a question by peter ducey over at
fox news
about inflation and how that might
affect the midterms and here was biden's
response
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound
stupid son of a biscuit is what he said
and and the great thing about that is
those are a few things that are great
about it but but first of all he's he's
speaking
this is being called a hot mic moment
and uh and those kinds of things happen
you know
like a real hot mic moment when you're
in front of cameras all the time there's
microphones around all the time and you
think the microphone is off or something
like that and uh and or maybe you're
wearing a microphone you forget that you
have it on and you just say something
off the cuff i mean those kinds of
things happen but in this case
he's sitting right in front of the
microphone he's not even muttering he's
just speaking into it
a microphone that he was just using a
second ago
so this is not he's like walking away
and uh got to take his mic off or he
said something that picked off pick up
picked up by a mic that he didn't know
was there no he's speaking directly into
the microphone
not because he wanted to be heard but
because he is clueless
because he's lost his mind
this is part these are these are all
symptoms of dementia
not aware of his surroundings
also prone to angry outbursts
um
and prone to just saying things that are
wildly inappropriate and kind and just
weird
these are all dementia symptoms
but
the other thing of course that you can't
help but but uh but think about is is
if
if uh
president trump
had said this
to
say a cnn reporter
imagine the reaction they would be
holding
candlelight vigils
to commemorate the tragedy for the next
50 years
every cnn anchor
that day and for the next week at least
it's the only thing they would talk
about
it's an attack on the free press
they would be in tears don lemon would
be crying
brian stelter would be in tears in a
fetal position on the floor
on camera
weeping over it
they would be bringing in counselors on
air
to counsel them through their ptsd i
mean can you imagine now of course
president trump called people sons of
[ __ ] all the time and i'm sure he
said that about the media many times and
not uh and
perfectly justified in
saying that as well
but if he had said it to their face on
camera
maybe jim acosta you stupid son of a
[ __ ] i would have i would have really
enjoyed that i wish you had said it
but
the theatrics that would follow that
be unlike anything we've seen
they'd be calling that this it was it
equates to 15 911s pearl harbor three
times
my god but joe biden says it and uh of
course it's
you know
no big deal
um and peter ducey to his credit has
just kind of laughed it off
because he's a you know he's a grown man
he has some he has some sense of dignity
so he's not going to get up there and
start crying about it
all right
let's see also we got this from fox
business it says when truth social
launches later this quarter the trump
media and technology group social media
platform will already have stringent
content moderation practices in place to
ensure that it is a family-friendly
online community
according to the company ceo devin nunes
both nunes and uh former president
donald trump
separately have told fox business that
truth social is expected to be up and
running by the end of the first quarter
of 2022
um
and uh what they're saying is that
um
they are going to here we go
the fox business it says that there's an
ai model that there be that they will be
using a silicon valley ai
thing that they'll be using
that will monitor truth social to offer
content moderation for posts to ensure
that sexually explicit content and posts
that include violence bullying hate
speech and spam never make it to the
platform
now
uh
if you're gonna start your own social
media platform
getting rid of filtering out all the
sexually explicit content is fantastic
that's the right thing to do
but if this is supposed to be and you're
calling it truth social
and this is supposed to be an answer to
twitter
i mean i like the idea all of these
attempts to
create alternative social media
platforms i i like i like it in theory i
think it's a good thing to do
and we also need
guys like trump that have got a lot of
money and they've got
um
they've already they already have a
platform and they have visibility and
they could drive you know if anyone can
drive people to a new platform donald
trump has that unique ability beyond
anybody else on earth
and so in theory it's a great idea
but
if you're using silicon valley ai
to filter out quote-unquote hate speech
and bullying
well then you're just making twitter
you're making a cut-rate twitter
there's no reason to leave twitter might
as well just keep using twitter
in fact the whole idea of making family
friend it sounds nice okay we have
family-friendly social media
but there can really be a
family-friendly social media because
social media itself is not is not a
family-friendly thing in order to be
family friendly has to be child-friendly
right
there's no such thing as child-friendly
social media
i don't care how good your ai is at
filtering out
explicit content
even if it does a perfect job it uh you
know bats a thousand in that department
you still shouldn't have your children
on social media
no matter what the content is
so there's no point in even trying to
make necessarily family-friendly social
media
but um
how about just social media that's
friendly to
to free speech
and also if you're calling it truth
social friendly to the truth
but we know the way silicon valley looks
at it
when they when they talk about and this
is their technology you're using and
when they say hate speech
what they really mean it kind of reminds
me of a it's a quote from the office
it's hate speech because they hate it
that's what they mean
and bullying is just stuff that they if
you take a stance or say something that
they don't like then it's bullying
that's how i got suspended from twitter
because i said that biological males are
men that's hate speech and bullying
if you're adopting that approach and
your answer to twitter i don't even see
the point
all right let's uh go back to the white
house here jenn pasake was asked i
thought a very good question
as we talk about ukraine and the
possibility of
conflict over ukraine with russia
the question to jim saki is hey if if if
europeans are don't seem very excited
about protecting europe then why should
we care that much about i mean why
should we be the ones to do it if they
won't do it that's the 10 million
question
over the last several decades of foreign
policy
all of these countries that the people
of these countries do not seem very
excited or determined to protect their
own homeland why should we do it
or we want to go into the middle east
and
protect democracy
for a bunch of people that don't want
democracy apparently
so let's see how jabasaki handles that
question
and then just more broadly um for years
nato members have fallen short of their
defense spending
commitments uh last year more than 60
percent of the alliance's 30 members
including half of the bucharest nine
that are right
uh near russia there um failed to meet
that uh their two percent gdp spending
commitment um if europeans aren't
willing to expend uh blood and treasure
on their self-defense why should
americans be expected to do so
well we are continuing to advocate for
um all members to uh reach uh the two
percent goal that has been the by the
president's position since he was the
vice president um so for many years now
uh i would say that uh we have a sacred
obligation under nato uh and we believe
it is also in our interest to support
our eastern flank countries uh and and
their security and also to be clear
about uh the uh the value we have as
americans which is that no country
should be able to take with force
um another country as as russia is
attempting to do at this point in time
a sacred obligation
with nato
uh no there's there's nothing sacred
first of all
in agreements that countries make
between themselves these are all these
are all political arrangements
it's not sacred i'll tell you as
if you work for the united states
government you you do have sacred
obligations your sacred obligations are
to
uh the people of the united states your
sacred obligation is to protect the
united states your sacred obligation is
to protect the united states border
to protect our sovereignty and our
people
and when we see that our country's in a
state of of
collapse
border is like a sieve
and our cities are collapsing crime
running rampant law order deteriorating
you know your sacred obligation is to do
something about those problems
that's what you're hired to do
i don't have any sacred sacred
obligation to ukraine
or our principle is that no country
should ever take over another country by
force
really in the entire world
so it's our job as america to make sure
that no country ever does that anywhere
to any other country
why
what about the countries involved
what about the country that's being
taken over
i mean do they have any obligation here
it was always funny to me when we hear
all of this
fretting especially by american
politicians that russia is expanding its
influence across the globe ah they're
expanding their influence
meanwhile these very same politicians
and people in government i just heard
from gen posaki they think that america
should have influence over every single
country on earth
they think we should potentially have a
say in what happens in every single
country on the globe
or worried about russia's influence
so here's what i want to pass along for
anyone in the audience if you're
listening to this and uh maybe you
disagree with what i'm saying and you
feel very strongly that uh we you know
we have a sacred obligation to ukraine
and we have to go protect ukraine we
also have to protect um
as she says the eastern flank of europe
uh even though the europeans themselves
don't seem to care that much about it
are not investing almost anything in
doing that but we have to do it
so if you feel that way if you feel
strongly about it
that we should expend
uh not just money but more importantly
lives
to go die potentially on ukrainian soil
to protect ukraine from russia then
here's what i would i want to pass this
on it's a very helpful link and uh take
out maybe take out a a pencil pen or
pencil and write this down it is um
immigrationukraine.com
slash citizenship dash of dash ukraine
again i'll give it to you immigration
ukraine.com citizenship dash of dash
ukraine and just plug that
address in there and it's going to pull
up
the ukrainian immigration bureau website
and it's all written in english very
very in a very handy way and it's going
to give you the process to become a
citizen of ukraine
and this is what i would really
recommend for anyone that cares that
much about ukraine
absolutely go to the website
start the process move to ukraine
become a citizen
and then join the military and in fact i
think and i was just i was looking
through this briefly
i'll have to do i'll have to do a deeper
dive and i could give you the
maybe information tomorrow but i believe
that you can actually move there
and uh be and join the military first
and then and then kind of earn your
citizenship that way
so you could also call them there's
numbers you can call and everything but
absolutely this is what for anyone that
cares that much if you think that um
you know american parents
should send their sons and even now
their daughters
to go die
to protect ukraine that's how strongly
you feel about it
then please go to this website leave
this country become a citizen of ukraine
and you can fight and die yourself for
it
a couple other clips i want to play for
you here are
the ladies of the view explaining why
they may never ride the subway again
without a mask and they never go out in
public again without a mask because of
all the things we've learned since the
pandemic listen
i think there's a prudence we've learned
with the mass the hand sanitate uh hand
sanitizing that kind of like 911 with
flying is always going to be here now
there's a new normal in the beginning
when at post 911 people didn't want to
fly and the security measures felt like
uh how do we do this you know and now
it's the norm i think some of the things
we've learned in this pandemic are going
to stay the same i may never write a
subway again without a mask i may never
go indoors to big crowds and never feel
comfortable without a mask and that's up
to me to do that
by the way i have to get on the show
um this my next stop on daytime tv i've
already we've done dr phil and my next
step has to be the view
this is my this is my ultimate dream is
to be on the view um
i could die you know i i could retire
after that
and and i could die a happy man if i
could just get on the view
i think everyone needs to reach out to
the to the people of the view and demand
in fact that they feature the number one
best-selling lgbt children's author in
the world on their show anything less
their refusal to bring me on the show
would be an act of gay erasure and
homophobia
as far as the point being made here such
as is uh she says well because of
everything we've learned during the
pandemic that's why i i just can't i
can't be in large crowds again without a
mask can't run right a subway because of
what we learned
what have we learned exactly
what what what have you learned what did
you learn during the pandemic about
viruses that you didn't know before
and that makes you want to wear a mask
out in public
did you not know that there were
potentially germs and viruses
in the air when you're around other
people
did you not know that the subway
is did it just occur to you that the
subway in new york is can be a kind of a
dirty place
i'm pretty sure you knew that before i
know i did
so here's what i'll tell you
i didn't learn and it's not because i
i'm not open to learning
i'm open to learning but i have not
learned
a single thing
about viruses or masks
or vaccines for that matter that i
didn't already know
so i know that viruses exist i know
germs exist i know that people can get
sick i know that you could be around
other people who are sick and that they
can get you sick
in fact we've known that ever since the
germ theory of disease was first
developed we've known that for a long
time
and i knew it
and yet
i would still go around in public as i
do now without a mask
because i have had conducted a risk
benefit analysis
and decided that the risk is not enough
that would necessitate me changing my
lifestyle to that extent
you know what i had also judged that
that you know things like breathing
fresh air
not a lot of that on a subway but still
in general breathing fresh air
is more important to me
than
trying to protect myself from any
potential viruses out there by wearing a
mask
that's it's more important
um being able to show my face in public
and to see other people's faces that is
more important to me
than
protecting myself from a virus
that's the calculation i made up until
two years ago and i continue to make now
and the thing is every other person in
the country every single one all 330
million plus of them
had made the same calculation
whether consciously or not because they
all we all knew that masks existed we
all knew viruses existed we all knew
germs existed
and yet nobody was going out in public
with a mask on
with rare exception
you know you have someone who's very
sick someone's going through their
immune system is very is very weak in
maybe going through chemotherapy or
something you know rare exception
everybody else going out without masks
on
not because they didn't know but because
they had done
even if just subconsciously the risk
benefit analysis
so it's not that you learn new things
it's that your priorities changed
or maybe it's better to say that you've
been conditioned
and she's proudly admitting it
oh yeah i've been i've been conditioned
by the fear camp the panic porn from the
government
so much so that it's it's changed the
way that i see
my life it's changed the way that i see
people
and she's proud to admit it
in fact the comparison that she makes is
apt
where she talks about the tsa and how oh
so totally normal going to the tsa
everyone's fine with it
yeah it is normal in that the tsa is in
every single airport and you can't avoid
them
but i'm not fine with it
in fact every time i go through airport
security i am very much aware and
cognizant of the fact that this is all
theater that's all it is
there's really there was there was never
any real good reason to federalize
airport security
especially when 911
was in many ways the result of failures
of the federal government to prevent it
and not because they didn't have
opportunities
so the federal government gets to come
in and take over airport security when
they drop the ball
so i'm cognizant of that every single
time i go through this is all pointless
um
and
not to mention we put all of this
intense focus on airplanes
as if that's the only place a terrorist
can attack
i mean a terrorist could just put a
suicide bomb on and walk into any
crowded place
and kill at least as many people as they
would kill by taking down a plane
so it doesn't even make any sense anyway
i i either either federalize and have uh
tsa military security everywhere in the
country at every public event
or don't have it at all
and leave it to the individual airports
and so on to deal with the security
i'm aware of that i think about it every
single time
what she's just admitting is that she's
not a she's not a critical thinker and
she because she's easily conditioned
and so for her like unfortunately many
many people in this country
the government just has to put something
in place you put a new policy or
procedure in place
and maybe at first maybe she'll be kind
of critical of it or skeptical for a few
days or hours
but just keep it there for a little bit
longer and suddenly she it's just part
of her life now and she stops
questioning it
because she doesn't have the critical
thinking faculties to question things
that are quote unquote normal the moment
they become normal she can't question
them anymore
and she's quite proud to admit it
pretty amazing
all right what else we got here this is
from the washington free beacon uh
virginia governor glenn youngkin on
wednesday overhauled the state's office
of diversity equity and inclusion
to focus on economic opportunity
parental rights and protecting unborn
children
the governor announced the change in an
executive order naming former heritage
foundation executive angela saylor as
the office's director younkin's
executive order also expands the scope
of the office beyond standard diversity
issues it directs the office to
eliminate disparities in prenatal care
and be an ambassador for unborn children
young can also announce that he would
seek to change the name of the
department uh to the office of diversity
opportunity and inclusion so rather than
diversity equity and inclusion out the
diversity opportunity at inclusion
ralph northam former governor
established the office in 2019 and uh
and
he he did that okay was it was that yeah
it was after his uh
blackface
faux pas
became public and then that this was his
one of his ways of paying reparations
was to establish an office of diversity
equity and inclusion
now
this this is a lot of people on the
right are kind of celebrating this and
saying this is another good move by
glenn younkin and don't get me wrong
glenn yonkin has done a lot right in his
first couple weeks in office
i would dare say he's had the best first
week in office of any governor in my
lifetime i can't think of anything but
yeah the bet he had the best first day
he did more in one day
than many governors
will do in their entire tenure
so a lot of credit to him for that
but this i don't like
um this i'm not a fan of
now having an ambassador for the unborn
focusing on parental rights on the
rights of children
all that stuff is great
but to do it within the framework
of the office of diversity equity and
inclusion i don't like that
no we don't what you should be doing is
not overhauling the office of diversity
equity and inclusion an office that as
we know it's only been around for two
years
and it was just it it was it was formed
as a pr stunt by the previous governor
so what do you do with that you just
come in and get rid of it
that's it don't overhaul it get rid of
it fire everybody that works for it
and be done with it
and if you want to have a separate
program or office or something
that is focused on the rights of the
unborn or parental rights fantastic do
that
but to overhaul
this office and then rename it a little
bit i think is the wrong move
um
what we have to stop doing what i talk
about all the time
this mistake that we make as
conservatives by adopting the left's
framework for things
so we're going to take the leftist
framework
of
diversity equity and inclusion
and just use that to advance say the
pro-life agenda
it it never works
and it's pointless because who's it
supposed to appeal to
it's not like you're gonna convince the
people on the left to say oh well if the
pro-life movement is
is part of an effort for diversity
equity then i'm in favor of it
i mean they might be stupid they're not
that stupid
and everybody on the right we don't need
that so who exactly are you appealing to
this is part of the thing that we again
conservatives will often do it's a it's
a strategy i just think it's a mistaken
one
where we're gonna say to the left oh you
know what we're better at living by your
values than you are
you you think that you care about
diversity equity inclusion tolerance but
you don't no the left they're the real
intolerant ones no i'll i'll show you
how to be tolerant
it's always the wrong move
so a lot good a lot of good from glenn
younkin not this and uh we gotta call we
gotta call out the bad when we see it i
think still
a lower mortgage rate can make quite a
difference on your budget it's true you
could save hundreds of dollars a month
simply by refinancing to one of these
incredibly low rates think of how much
that can help then pick up the phone and
call american financing and do it now
before rates get any higher i mean you
cannot miss out on what's available
right now especially since there's no
cost to get started you'll get a free no
obligation mortgage review from a salary
based mortgage consultant they'll walk
you through the custom loan options and
find every way possible to save you up
to a thousand dollars a month without
resetting your term you can choose any
uh term 10 years and over and you have
the potential to skip two mortgage
payments so don't put your refi off any
longer call 866 569 forty seven eleven
that's eight six six five six nine forty
seven eleven again that's eight six six
five six nine forty seven eleven one
more time it's eight six six five six
nine forty seven eleven or visit
americanfinancing.net
american financing nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
let's get now to our comment section
all right dailywire.com sweet baby
comments and we've got uh we're going
back to the video comments today and
let's start we'll just go through the
clips here let's start with clip one
hey matt i thought you were brilliant on
dr phil and i wanted to conduct an
experiment in my own home and see if my
six-year-old daughter and my
three-year-old son could tell me the
difference between a man and a woman and
what a woman is i want to ask you
something
what is a woman
a female
what makes a woman different from a man
boobs
well there you have it spg for life
horrifying horrifying you you have
conditioned these poor children
to be transphobes this early in life
i for one am no this is a
yeah this is well it just goes to show
uh and if i were and you know if i would
ask my kids the same question i would
get very similar answers
these are concepts that are so simple
that literally a three-year-old can
understand them
until the indoctrinators come in and
confuse the kids intentionally so it's
one it's one big like we talked about
last week
we we have
we're standing on the firm ground of
truth of a very simple truth
that the three-year-old can understand
how do you know someone's a woman uh
boobs there you go
really it's that simple most of the time
um
we're standing on the firm ground of
truth
and all the left does is they just they
don't have answers for themselves all
they can try to do is confuse you and
unfortunately with kids it's it's easy
to confuse them because they're just
kids
so keep those keep those young children
away from the public school system
please
all right let's go to number two
hey sweet daddy walsh my name is shelby
and i recently fled california and moved
to tennessee and i'm honored to be
living in the same state as my sweet
daddy
um i just wanted to say that i also keep
my house pretty cool usually around 62
to 64 degrees even though it's pretty
chilly here in tennessee
and i just wanted to let you know that
some of us women are on the same page as
you
and i'm standing standing with you on
this one instead of
your wife but keep the house cold helps
you sleep better and thanks for the
great show
yeah this this sweet daddy thing is just
it it
we should have thought about this before
we did the video comments
it's a whole different experience
hearing it
and the other thing is there are a lot
of new um
viewers on to the matt walsh show this
week which which is great a lot of
people discovering
the you know the show because of dr phil
and
i i don't even know what they must be
thinking
these comments
from people calling me sweet daddy
watching like what what is what what is
happening in the show they must be
wondering and the thing is if we never
explained the sweet baby gang that's one
of the rules but even if i did i'm not
sure would make it any less weird
so i got to think about this
let's just uh thanks for the comment
let's let's uh let's move on
[Music]
that's what a good member would do
life
i love that we're making the world a
better place um one one shopping cart at
a time so this is this is really
a movement
and at the same time we are
continuing to just confuse everyone so
the other people in the parking lot
watching someone return their their
shopping cart while chanting return or
die
very confusing
uh one more comment here let's watch
this
hey matt huge fan of the show so is my
buddy cosmo back here um i just wanted
to throw in a quick comment to see if
maybe you and michael knowles would be
willing to team up and create some sort
of uh
dating site dating app connected with a
daily wire um because you know i
feel like a lot of single people like
myself share in a lot of these values um
you know you know being a conservative
being a christian
all that sort of thing it's it just
seems to be very hard right now to try
to find the right match so
um i
wanted to throw it out there see if you
guys are open to doing something like
that because i feel like my ideal match
would obviously be christian and
conservative and you know more most
importantly
they would be a member of the sweet baby
gang so uh so i think if you and knowles
teamed up on something like that it
would be amazing i don't know talk it
over with ben but i think it'd be a
great idea help us single people out man
um huge fan of the show again um sbg for
life yeah i uh i like the idea of having
our own dating app first of all why
would i include nulls in it this is
because the reason i like it is because
we make a lot of money off of that so i
like the profit part of it and i would
just keep all the money for myself
but in terms of actually solving the
problem with the dating scene i'm not
sure another app would really do it you
know i'm sure there are plenty of um
of i'm sure there are plenty of you know
christian dating apps or whatever out
there uh that are they're allegedly
catering they may not be specifically
catering to the sweet baby gang
unfortunately but
um
plenty of apps that are supposed to
cater to that audience and i'm not sure
if that's probably better than using one
of these other apps but it doesn't
really solve a lot of the problems that
we talked about yesterday where i mean
the problems are just
way too many options just the whole act
of like going through faces and swiping
the ones you don't like
uh it's just kind of dehumanizing and
inherently dismissive in a way that just
doesn't put you on the right footing for
trying to find
a real relationship and then there's the
problem like we talked about that that
it's this is all it's all it is all
exclusively visual
right or almost exclusive so you've got
the picture and then maybe a little bit
of a description of the person in their
profile
but most of these determinations are
made
visually
and that kind of flips things on their
head especially for women because women
um are not nearly as visual as men and
so if a woman meets a man in person
it doesn't even take that long like she
the physical part of it is going to be
helpful
but she's going to pick up on a lot more
right personality intelligence just kind
of their aura you know women have kind
of an intuition about those things and
that none of that is there with the
picture so
um that's just a long way of saying i'm
not sure that any app can solve these
problems i think i think the real way to
solve the problem is to get away from
the apps
if anything
you know maybe go back to traditional
sort of matchmaking
type services
or try to go out as hard as it must be
and i don't envy it at all and view you
at all if you're in this position
but really you got to go out in public
and try to meet people in person
i don't know where you would begin to do
that but i think that's what you have to
start thinking about
because these apps come with problems
that just can't be solved by another app
all right um
let's see moose chuckle says matt your
show was late to start but as a diligent
follower i was here waiting will you
please put matt walsh bobble heads in
the online store
if you will buy them
i have no shame i mean you can go to the
online store at dailywire.com go to the
mattwall store
and you will clearly see that i have no
shame at all and i if if there's an
audience for it we will sell it
there was an audience
a disturbingly large audience
for t-shirts with pictures of me and a
diaper and so we put it up to sell okay
so we'll we'll do the bobbleheads too
all right friend of jesus says i'm
single 36 years old i'm a pastor and yes
the dating scene is rather toxic i feel
as if i stand upon an infinite plane of
destruction
stretching out in all directions toward
a dark miserable empty sunset and my
only hope is that god might somehow
bring these dry bones to life
i don't know if that's a quote from
something but if that's your own words
then uh
rather depressing but also see the fact
that you can write that
alone means that women would be
interested in you the fact that you have
the ability to write and think that way
and
um express yourself in in that way
but that's again it's something that's
it's hard to put that foot forward in a
dating app and that's part of the
problem
because what you just put there
quite beautiful really
and depressing
you know but that's not something you
want to put in a dating profile
but the ability to speak that way and
write that way is something that women
do find interesting
um
let's see
kevin says hey matt i've got a question
that relates to two topics you've
frequently discussed marriage and dating
and also porn if you if a guy has a porn
addiction should he wait to start dating
a girl until he gets control of it
and uh defeats it yeah i would say
absolutely
um because
if the porn habit
is being indulged alongside establishing
a relationship with someone that's
that's not going to work
and you're just setting yourself up for
failure setting her up for failure her
up for feelings of uh betrayal and all
of that
so i would
i would focus on on getting that under
control and then moving on
um
and uh finally scott says there are two
possible outcomes after going on dr phil
you either start having nightmares and
are traumatized or you gain over 50 000
subscribers on youtube
in under a week yeah well it's actually
more than 50 000 not to brag but
and now i've just been working overtime
to alienate so many of those new
subscribers so we'll see how many we
have left by the end of the week if you
haven't heard of adam carolla's new
daily wire exclusive comedy series truth
yeller it's about time you do in the
next episode airing this thursday adam
gets controversial by mocking hunter
biden and the way our overlords are
attempting to crate train your kids tj
miller of silicon valley deadpool big
hero 6 and moore joins adam to drop some
comedy gold and prove that he knows how
to identify a grandma killer which is a
good skill to have so head to
dailywire.com subscribe and use code
miller for 25 off your membership look
out for the new episode with tj miller
dropping this thursday
and also the daily wire is constantly
working to bring you the truth that's
why we've launched our own publishing
wing dw books and we're proud to be
publishing two books that are actively
fighting the left's monopoly on
storytelling the first is 12 seconds in
the dark by sergeant mattingly the book
is the true story of what really
happened the night of the tragic brianna
taylor shooting mattingly a 20-year
police veteran takes readers inside his
department's response and debunks the
lies that have recklessly been shared
with the public dw books is also
publishing fiery but mostly peaceful by
uh julio rosas who puts back pulls back
the curtain and sets the record straight
on the black lives matter riots that
broke out across the country
in 2020 roses uh who was reporting from
the ground gives his first hand
experience of the
of the riots and exposes the media's
attempts to convince americans that the
fatal and destructive riots were somehow
peaceful
i'm so grateful to have these brave
truth tellers on board can't wait for
you to hear their stories both are
available for pre-order now on amazon or
anywhere you buy books online now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
though it would seem that the daily
cancellation was made for her lena
dunham has i don't think ever been
cancelled on this show sadly she dropped
off the face of the earth right around
the time when i began this segment some
might even speculate that the timing was
not a coincidence perhaps she fled from
public view in order to avoid the wrath
of the daily cancellation she was
briefly back on the radar early in 2021
when she released a plus-sized fashion
line that was immediately slammed by
critics for not catering to fat people
enough the world crowd claimed that
dunham's new brand failed the
inclusivity test because though it had
clothing for large people it did not
have any for very large and very very
large people
so dunham's attempt to relaunch her
career crashed and burned as the woke
zombies swarmed the rocket before
takeoff and devoured everybody inside
which is probably why they need bigger
clothing
but now dunham is making her real
comeback and last week a lengthy puff
piece in the hollywood reporter
featuring glamour shots like this one
which you can see here
there you go
uh feast your eyes on that for a moment
announced that dunham was back on the
scene and she's not going anywhere and
her new film
sharp stick has debuted the website
moviemaker.com quotes her q a after the
premiere at sundance where she explains
what the film is about and what she
hopes to achieve with it the article
says quote lena dunham's sharpstick
shows the porn industry in a rare
positive light she says that was 100
intentional
now
side note you're of course filled with a
deep sense of foreboding at the thought
that lena dunham directed and starred in
a film about porn
but just put your mind at ease
we're not playing any clips
we will stick instead with what she has
said about the movie and continuing she
says i think many of us were especially
people who started maybe like reading
second wave feminist literature early we
were shaped by a kind of feminism that
maybe didn't give porn it's due as
something that can be really healing for
people dunham who directed wrote and
acted in sharp sticks said saturday in a
q a after the film's world premiere at
sundance quote i think we have found we
have enough messaging in society and
probably in my 20s i contributed to it
that said like porn is ruining sex and
it's making it so hard for people but i
really wanted this to show the way that
porn can liberate people and that it's
an industry that's just as complicated
as hollywood and as vast and probably
more prolific and i think that's really
important for us to recognize the very
healthy role that porn can play and the
important role that porn actors play in
shaping people's identities
now we should mention here that dunham's
new film has been described even by
mainstream critics who are predisposed
to appreciate dunham's work as quote
heinous hollow amateurish cringe
uncomfortable and problematic
those are also all the adjectives that i
would use to describe a lena dunham
starring film about the wonders of porn
even though i haven't seen it i never
will because i'd sooner scoop my own
eyes out with a rusty spoon then
watch something like that but even if
the film fails to impress the critics
the basic message is one that would
generally enjoy wide agreement among
many people in our culture especially on
the left
porn
is liberating and empowering we're told
healing even as dunham claims
is that true
in a word no
pornography is about as liberating and
powering and healing as heroin
when dunham calls it all of those things
what she really means is that it's
pleasurable
and she draws no distinction between
pleasure and liberation
or pleasure and joy or pleasure and love
because for her as for so many others in
our culture momentary pleasure is the
highest good that we can hope to achieve
a life packed full of moments of surface
level pleasure
is mistaken then for a fulfilled and
joyful life
that is these two things are mistaken
until you look around and see the
results
because if porn is so wonderful and
healing then you'd expect for one thing
that the people in the porn industry
would be the most joyful and healed of
all
and yet we find among people in that
line of work
sky-high rates of suicide and drug abuse
just as we find among prostitutes
and the people who appear in porn videos
are just prostitutes after all
as for the viewer when you look at porn
you become a faceless onlooker peering
like a stalker through the window of a
motel while someone else has sex with a
hooker they hired on the street corner
but it's worse than that really because
it's less honest
at least the peeping tom is forced to
reckon with his behavior he's out in the
cold ducking behind bushes watching
these two go at it
and from there he sees the whole act the
whole dismal exchange he doesn't get to
dip in and out of a dozen scenes
consuming portions and glances before
breezing along to the next
he doesn't get to close the tab when
it's all over and act like nothing
happened
he's there as a stranger in the dark and
he has to go home and deal with the
reality of what he's become
the porn viewer on the other hand feels
insulated
what he's doing really is identical in a
lot of ways but it doesn't seem that way
because it's safer it's a screen not a
window
she's an amateur porn star not a
prostitute
his actions are legal
even normal by today's standards
well he's different he tells himself
he's better
that's a lie because everything about
porn is a lie porn makes human beings
into objects
it turns a sexual act into something
transactional and mercenary
you know sex between a married couple in
the privacy of their bedroom is an
expression of love and devotion so then
what does sex on camera for the viewing
public express
and what does the viewer what does the
viewer express by viewing it
i mean the supporters of porn they're
the first ones to claim
that this is an act of expression
okay
i'll take you at your word what is it
expressing exactly
certainly not empowerment
a woman who feels like she has power
over her life does not [ __ ] herself out
to the porn industry and a man or woman
for that matter who feels like he has
power over his own life does not make a
[ __ ] of himself by watching it
the porn industry along with sites like
pornhub and so on they profit off of the
willful self-degradation of both the
viewer and the view to the tune of many
billions of dollars
you know it's hard to argue that
consumers are ever really empowered in
their role as consumer
even when they're consuming something
innocuous or morally neutral
i've never felt empowered while waiting
in line at target
which isn't to say that there's anything
morally wrong with shopping at a real
retail outlet it's just to say that i
would never try to find anything poetic
or beautiful about the experience
so then what about consumers of the porn
industries product
if you're not empowered while pushing a
cart around the aisles of a big box
retailer
how in the hell could you be empowered
in your role as a faceless third party
participant in virtual prostitution
and how could the prostitutes themselves
be empowered
no everyone involved is being used
dehumanized and objectified
far from being healed they're being
damaged
though they may find some pleasure in
the harm being done to them
just as you may find pleasure in the
brain damage you suffer from drinking
too much whiskey
that can't be confused with joy
or at least of all empowerment
and this is all why today finally we
have the honor to say to lena dunham you
are canceled
i'll leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vladowski the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22. joe biden
taps tom hanks to get people to like him
the supreme court considers striking
down affirmative action and the ruling
class really wants you to eat bugs check
it out on the michael knowles show